thank you for joining me at the
understanding the Ranga crisis race
religion and violence in Burma my name
is Elliott precede Freeman I'm a
graduate candidate here in the
anthropology department and I'm honored
to be joined by this esteemed panel but
also saddened at the circumstances that
have brought us here I'm going to start
by thanking the people who have made
this possible we've had generous support
from the Pointer fellowship in
journalism which has brought Francis
Wade the author of the new book on memos
Muslims and the violence that's being
done to them and then we also were able
to bring a number of other people here
through the support of the Council for
Southeast Asian Studies here and the
Macmillan Center and the shell Center
for International Human Rights I'm going
to go through some intros really fast to
tell you who these people sitting in
front of you are then we're gonna I'm
gonna do a little bit of background on
the hanger with / or hinge people and
the conflict that has splashed across
the headlines over the last couple of
months then I'm going to hand it over to
Francis and then the rest of the panel
to speak that'll probably take us
through about 4 5 15 at which point
we're gonna open it up to your comments
and we have a lot of people in this room
who have experience with Myanmar and the
region and we want them to contribute as
well last but not least we have a film
screening of a short film it's about
it's a little over 15 minutes long on
it's called situate which is one of the
cities in Rakhine State and it features
a Muslim woman young woman and a
Buddhist young man and kind of tells the
conflict through their story
it was obviously done before this recent
bout of violence but it is quite timely
given what has happened since okay so in
terms of who you're looking at today we
have Francis Wade there
the person the reason why we're here in
the first place is a journalist
specializing in Myanmar in Southeast
Asia
he began reporting on Myanmar in 2009
with the exiled media concern called
democratic voice of Burma based in
northern Thailand before going to cover
in depth the transition from military
rule to this new quasi democratic system
that we have now in as he did that he
got more and more involved in the story
of both hindu people and the challenges
that the rest of myanmar muslims are are
facing his book is called which
published in Zed books in 2000 of 2017
is Mia's enemy within Buddhist violence
and the making of a Muslim other
then we have a choice ni is ethnic
Joaquin Burmese activist working in
Aragon state his organization the Quinta
peace and Development Institute is one
of the only local organizations working
to Hofstra dialogue between religion and
rock I'm people currently he is Alliance
for historical dialogue and
accountability fellow at Columbia
University working on a project
documenting stories of the victims of
the communal violence in the area and he
grew up there and often we people don't
get an insider's view of what it's like
to grow up in these areas and to live
with them and he'll be able to provide
us with insights on his work today and
also what it looked like in the recent
past then we have a recent joiner to the
panel uma Winn who's the director of the
smile education Development Foundation
in Rangoon or Yangon depending on on
your proclivities founded in 2007 in
response to rising intolerance and
discrimination in Burma so this is
someone who can talk not only about the
Roja issue but also the broader context
of challenges of interfaith inter-ethnic
interracial harmony or lack thereof
in the country and finally last but not
certainly not least is James E Scott
political scientist and will lapse
political scientist hopefully not an
anthropologist who is a comparative
scholar of agrarian and non-state
societies subaltern politics and
anarchism with a particular focus on
Burma and he'll be able to provide some
context and some insights on where we're
going from here so one of the more
contentious issues about the rehén jaw
is who are they from
Burmese nationalists perspective or from
really a Burmese perspective almost
across society where there's very little
agreement on anything there seems to be
a consensus these days that the row
hinges are not from the land of Burma
itself now they've been concentrated in
this area what's called Rakhine State to
the west of the country particularly to
the north close to to Bangladesh and the
narrative that were the belief is that
these people have come in with the
colonial encounter when the British
governed Burma as part of broader India
and so at this point there were no
nation state borders that people could
cross and the British liked the Indians
for their ability to speak English their
networks that took them beyond the
province of Burma and so there was a
huge amount of people from South Asia
that came into the country at that that
point now the unfortunate part of this
narrative is that it cuts off everything
that came between it and one of the
things that that Jim Scott focuses on in
his work is to try to upend a kind of
tyranny of the map that prevents us from
seeing into the the past without those
lines on the map that would divide
spaces that weren't so title E divided
and what I mean by that is that Rakhine
kingdoms weren't title
in that area but rather we're
fluctuating kind of like accordions and
they got bigger and smaller and these
places these kingdoms tended to make
themselves run through the collection of
bodies to work in wet rice plantations
essentially and people don't really like
to do that as he shows and they they run
away and so what happens is that these
societies were supported by slave
gathering and just massive population
movements in general so these historical
Soria graphical I guess discourse is
about what you know the people were
always there and these are interlopers
neglect the fact that people were
flooding across what are now borders for
a very long time and the people who now
see themselves as revenge' likely came
during this pre-colonial period that I'm
gonna skip over a bunch of history that
I think my colleagues can better speak
about but I wanted to give that a little
bit of background first and then kind of
bring us up to speed and the current
violence and situate that in just in in
terms of what's happened so that Francis
doesn't have to spend too much of his
time going over that basically since
2012 there's been a number of
configurations of violence that have
forced were injured out of the country
there was a recent attack in 2016 and
then people who are claiming to
represent the Raja in 2017 called al
Rahim just solidarity army struck in a
coordinated attack on a bunch of
military posts this was used as pretense
by the Miam our army to strike back in
with extreme prejudice against not just
the people who were responsible for
these actions but also the entire
population so we're talking two hundred
and eighty villages destroyed thousands
of houses torched 600,000 people
ultimately pushed across the border into
Bangladesh and this slide shows
generally some of the
where people have ended out that ended
diaspora and all thanks to al-jazeera
from whom I took these lovely maps um
now in terms of the political situation
now that the rajendra are largely
effectively stateless and they don't
have citizenship for a number of reasons
that my colleagues can speak about but
more importantly I think even if they
did it wouldn't necessarily matter and
what I mean by that is there's some
revenge' who gave up claimed to their
ethnicity they took the name Bengali
this is in me bone and they were given
the pink card of citizenship that is
supposed to allow you to enter into the
fold of the nation and they still
weren't allowed to leave their village
so this is a deeper issue than just
having citizenship this is a kind of
complete uttering of a population to the
point where they're not accepted as part
of the fabric of society and so
hopefully today we'll be able to talk
about why that is what it means to
belong in this country at this
particular moment of democratization
when markets are opening up resources
are flooding in and perhaps who you are
and to which group you belong helped
predicate whether you can access those
resources whether you can be a part of
of the country so I with no further ado
I'm going to hand it over to Francis and
he's going to be able to explain what he
found in his book and hello everyone
Thank You Elliott as I understand
there's been some coverage of the most
recent violence in the press here
probably not enough as ever it's a
situation that I think many of us had
been warning might happen for several
years now one of those kind of sad
desperate tales of the world waking up
to a crisis perhaps to this all too late
the accounts many of which I'm sure
you've seen have been pretty appalling I
was in Bangladesh in
September mid to late September and by
that point 400,000 Rangers crossed over
in what is believed to be the most
concentrated refugee flow since the
Rwanda genocide so there are upwards of
100,000 crossing each week many were in
deplorable mental physical condition
because the Myanmar government has
largely blocked access to northern
reclines state where this campaign where
this military campaign has happened to
outside observers we've had to rely on
eyewitness testimony try to triangulate
that with satellite imagery in order to
build at least a partial picture of
what's happened as Elliott said 200 odd
villages have been partially or totally
destroyed the Myanmar military has
committed massacres in concert with
reclines civilians and I visited several
hospital wards in Bangladesh while I was
there and there were they were full of
people with very serious wounds children
with bullet wounds burns from when the
house has been torched it disappears
have been an indiscriminate campaign
despite both the government and the
military professing to be a targeted
counterinsurgency operation well I think
a lot of these reports have shocked so
too has the response from inside the
country both from the government and
from the civilian populace who seems to
have almost ran heed in support of the
military and that's what I want to
explore here to try and I guess look at
things from the perspective of the
population from those either
perpetrating or supporting the violence
because well I think there's been a lot
of coverage of the results of the
violence there's been less sort of
investigation into the motivations that
have driven it
I think this kind of crisis would be
shocking anywhere in the world perhaps
it's more so in Miyama because of
certain preconceived ideas that many of
us had about about the country and about
a population that had for so long seen
very resistant the divisive politics of
the military had been steadfastly in
opposition to military abuses which the
majority of the population had suffered
from themselves and so that's the first
thing I'd like to address how the ranger
have been so we have this we have this
community of stateless persons that are
essentially quarantined in a corner of
the country Elliot said they're
concentrated there but I think there's
more to it than that they're not really
allowed to leave that part of the
country and yet they still become this
source of national hysteria and I think
it's because they've been constructed or
largely because they've been constructed
as a threat the national community or
society both in reclines they and more
broadly so that is the first thing I'd
like to address how they've been
constructed as a threat as an enemy of
such magnitude that for decades they've
required containment controlling and now
expulsion and as I said while I think
the shock of the outside world is
understandable it's also been to a
degree fed by quite a binary vision that
I think we had of the state and society
in Myanmar which was formed during
military rule that still seems to linger
of this bad military versus good
virtuous society that's being completely
upended now and I think it's worth
looking what's happened to radically
upset that quite conventional view and
how wrong in dangerously so many of us
were to believe in such a sort of
simplistic state society dichotomy in
the first
so that's the second point the final
point that I'll look at why does this
threat the threat of the Ranger pose why
does that need to be addressed now as
Myanmar appears to be moving very full
serenely towards a democracy of sorts is
this violence a bug in the
democratization process or is it in fact
product of democratization and I think
for those of us who have been watching
the spread of religious violence across
the transition this has been you know
quite a frightening quite a shocking
experience burt's it's not necessarily
new at least this show of loathing for
the Ranger isn't especially new so I
want to kind of go back a little bit and
look at some of the context for this and
I'm picking all the various strands to
what's happening now it would take days
weeks we haven't got the room for that
long so I think I just focused primarily
on first and foremost why and how
they've been constructed as a threat
because I think it's that that sort of
underpinned why the population feels
they need to be completely rid of them
why it's supporting what is essentially
a campaign of ethnic cleansing as Elliot
mentioned over the past five years there
have been several waves of violence
between rocaille and Buddhist and Muslim
reinjure those have been more communal
in their expression at least than the
current one which is an over to campaign
with civilian support and when I've
spoken with Rakhine nationalists in
particular who have participated in
previous acts of violence against rehén
jur there's often this refrain this
common refrain that is the goes sort of
you know if we don't protect our race if
we don't protect our people if we don't
protect our nation then it will be
destroyed and that was a fear that was
very much pushed by the military very
deliberately so
and some of you may be aware of the
slogan of the immigration ministry that
when the earth quote-unquote the earth
won't swallow a race to extinction
but another race will sow it both evokes
this idea of a threats either in the
country or outside of the country but
also this idea which has been central to
the nationalist ideology of the military
which is that there's one sort of
cohesive us in Myanmar and that
narrative of an indigenous us pitched
against them Outsiders of sort of
varying guises extends way back before
this current show of violence and it
kind of prompts what is an obvious
statement that what's happened now
hasn't emerged from thin air every
campaign of mass violence the world over
has particular processes both large and
small so local national political
engineering hyperlocal antagonisms
between groups and individuals and me
Amma is no different I only really have
time to look what's happened since 2012
and I'm grateful for Elliot detailing
some of the history prior to that the
reason why I begin in 2012 when the
first wave of violence happened between
Ranger and Rakhine is because I see that
as a vital precursor to what's happening
now it really I suppose marked a turning
point in the relations between the two
communities of the state and really
began to shape or reshape perceptions of
reinjure amongst the broad swath of
Myanmar society
and hopefully Joe Sam will talk a bit
more about this but prior to the 2012
violence according to both Rakhine Emery
Hindu I've spoken to since there was
there were inter-communal relations so
they both traded both communities traded
in marketplaces together they used to
sit in the same tea shops from what I
could tell they had an informal social
engage
many if not enjoyed at least willingly
tolerated that all changed very quickly
and very dramatically after the 2012
violence which began in June and lasted
around 4 days and led to the destruction
of several Muslim neighborhoods and
sittwe and villages elsewhere
both recliner mahindra villages were
destroyed after that rindy were confined
to camps villages ghettos this apparatus
of control grew up in the state that was
targeted at the revenger and that seemed
to have a curious curious effect McCain
had enthusiastically about this control
measures this segregation because it
meant the Ranger would be further
contained but from what I could gather
it really began to sort of animate this
idea that the range of presented a
threat
the reclined people to recline society
the segregation measures the camps that
grew up the sort of confinement of
reinjure to particular areas didn't seem
to provide also instill an ease within
recline people it almost well it did
wide and communal fissures but also I
suppose hardened fears that in said
inside of these camps inside of these
villages inside of these ghettos there
was something sinister lurking and
because there was no interaction between
what kind of a hinder after the 2012
violence it meant that there was no real
sort of countervailing interface into
information that would have corrected
those thought patterns so they really
began to lock in and kind of fester and
I think that was the most insidious
effect of the initial segregation that
began in 2012 not the material losses
that it caused but more the I suppose
deep some psychological effect it had on
amplifying fears about the Ranger about
this community and therefore heightening
the potential for more violence to take
place and this kind of acute segregation
I think created what was an enabling
environment for these perceptions of the
Ranger as a threat to develop and harden
and not just individual Ranger but the
entire community and after 2012 after
that violence as is often the case of
violence that happens along ethnic lines
or identity lines but kind of a hinge a
sharp be retreated into these sort of
separate physical enclaves that soon
became mental enclaves as well and that
caused group identities to sharpened
dramatically and it caused people to
really sort of look inwards for sort of
solidarity security rather than looking
outwards and so it seemed as if the more
sort of structural repression of the
reinjure didn't resolve the fears that
reclined felt of them it almost excited
them further and this was helped along
hugely by an uptick in information that
was being circulated by recline and by
sort of local and state media more
broadly about the rehén Jerr
that they were this sort of crusading
force bent on destroying the recurring
identity and that of Buddhism more
broadly and initially a lot of that
information that began circulating in
2012 referenced the rape and murder of
or a kind woman by three row hinder men
which had provided the trigger for the
first wave of violence in June 2012 but
it did it in a way that made not the not
merely the act of sort of you know three
Craven individuals not something that
was isolated from the broader dynamic
between recliner mahindra but more as a
direct expression of everything that was
dangerous in that dynamic between the
two groups and when local and state
media reported on that rape and murder
they often included the designate
Muslim or Bengali in brackets after the
suspects name in a way that made it seem
as if the group identity was at fault
and I think that really sort of
illustrates the kind of mental shift
that began to occur around 2012 in in
how I guess individual actions by our
Hindu were interpreted in group terms
and therefore eventually as we've seen
why it was necessary to respond against
the entire group rather than individual
Ramdas within the group and over time we
had calls from reclined monks for kind
politicians to completely break ties
with Ranger there are a kind people who
are caught sending rights to her injure
or smuggling medicine into camps they
would be beaten paraded with a traitor
sign around their neck through towns
leaflets began to be distributed around
the state capital sit way and other
towns the attacked international aid
groups who were assisting rehén jure
because they had been quote unquote
watering poisonous plants I keeping
alive a kind of toxic presence in
Rakhine society and this idea of the
sort of malevolent reinjure I think
really became a staple of McCain
imagination and more broadly the Burmese
imagination across the country and we'll
kind of get onto that I think there's a
fundamental point the the kind of
propaganda that began to be circulated
in 2012 and the kind of propaganda of
the circulators since the insurgent
attacks in August has tried to make and
some of you may have seen the sort of
the memes the pictures that are going
around of you know ray hinge of babies
carrying machetes and so on I think its
principle messages the war Ranger not
just the nascent insurgency need to be
dealt with and I spoken with countless
rakaia over the years who speak of a
kind of range of men that
Evelyn's that sort of always in born
innate but they have bad blood but it's
not something that can be reasoned with
or educated out of them and therefore
needs to be sort of exercise altogether
there is a very popular belief the the
Ranger identity is a political construct
in contrast to McCain recline ethnicity
or the Burma ethnicity moreover which is
believed to be something more I suppose
primordial or natural and because of
that there's belief the ranger are
claiming to be an indigenous group so
they can claim citizenship that would
then give them a platform to do whatever
one believes they want to do with the
country either is the my is it or
succeed from it there are sort of
varying narratives the narrative then
goes that because the range identity is
a political project in of itself then
everyone who subscribes to rindra to the
range identity is party to that project
and therefore sort of collectively
responsible for the actions of a few
within it so it's a way of looking at
things in very binary terms so no they
who act as one in the service of that
identity we has another defending
against there I suppose the sinister
project and we need to recognize that in
Myanmar these narratives are playing a
fundamental role in conditioning shaping
the de Vaca the violence and I suppose
determining how it's mutated from what
had been local communal violence into
something more substantial that's broad
in the military and attracted support
for the military the fear of the ranger
that really took hold after 2012
seem to have a contagious effect and
began to be voiced by communities across
the country that probably had little to
no contact with Ranger
and the rationales behind this fear
varied so reclaimer often talk in more I
suppose material can materialize indra
taking their land overwhelming their
resources but outside of reclined state
a more existential fear began to develop
the ranger are the vanguard of crusade
is the minds of the country weakened
buddhism and it placed the more recent
insurgency within a kind of universal
narrative of crusading Islamism and i
think because the religious dimension
has been pushed so unremittingly in
local media state media it's had the
effect of drawing in a far larger
community of resistors and therefore
kind of enlarging the in-group
dramatically so it's almost broadened
the identity component of the conflict
beyond what had been a local
contestation in Rakhine State between
McCain and rehén jure ethnic groups to
something much larger and which has
ramifications for the health of the
entire country the second topic I wanted
to tackle briefly was this quite binary
bad military good state good society
view that many had of Myanmar that's now
unraveled quite dramatically we have
so-called Democrats we have monks
espousing deeply hateful views of the
right Hindu community they have high
authority great influence people listen
to them I won't say a great deal on this
but except to say that I think it
provides a universal lesson of sorts
because there have been very little
interrogation of the political
opposition during military rule and it
seemed that there there was a kind of
assumption that because they stood
against the military that meant they
stood for democracy and for equal rights
for all without any sort of deep
questioning of and particularly of
senior figure heads within the next
for democracy of what their vision for
society was beyond the installment of su
Chi and the National League of democracy
what kind of qualities it might seek in
a new society how and if it would begin
to tackle the deep prejudices of the
military cultivated how a bridge the
sort of the very device of politicking
of the military and I think there's a
feeling that su Chi and the
pro-democracy movement more broadly has
betrayed its ideals but I think beyond
its broad appeals to quite a fav
conception of democracy we didn't really
know what those ideals were and that I
think provides a cautionary tale for
other transitional societies who have an
opposition that's always breathlessly
endorsed by Western governments without
much interrogation of their vision or
without much appreciation of what might
have come before them which in Myanmar's
case was a military which heavily
manipulated ethnic religious identities
that cultivated these violent contest
nations over who belongs and who doesn't
and as we've seen that's had an
insidious effect on the country and one
that I think functions well beyond the
party level and which will take more
than just political engineering to
really challenge that brings me to the
third topic which is the link between
the violence and the political
transition and I've tried to imagine
what might cause that curious but
familiar paradox of an advancing
democratization process and worsening
violence and of course there is a
history of communal antagonism in
Rakhine State and for sure there are
reclined nationalist politicians and
Burma politicians were broadly who see
violence as
ethically profitable in the sense that
particularly violence along ethnic lines
often causes people to identify more
closely with their ethnic group and if
there's a representative party then that
often translates into support for that
party
ergo votes should an election come round
so I think there's definitely been some
imaginations on strategic imaginations
on the part of the kind politicians but
I think we also need to look closer at
military rule and the fears and
anxieties that this produced in the
populace because it seems to be the case
that in Myanmar there's a fear that
democratization if it isn't pursued
selectively could in fact weaken the
standing of particular groups like the
recline rather than enfranchising them
and again I don't really have enough
time to unpack this funny but I think
one can make a broad statement that the
military during its time in power and
this is something that Elliot's done
some work on greatly limited the
conferring of political rights on the
population to the degree that those
rights appeared to be finite and so this
naturally gives rise to a fear that were
one community to be enfranchised fire
democratization then another community
would be disempowered so in the case of
the reclining Umrah hinge ER if the
Ranger were brought into the national
community and if they were to enjoy the
supposed fruits of democratization so
political enfranchisement economic gain
access to resources then they would be
gifted a platform that would allow them
to rise to an equal footing as Rakhine
and therefore begin the studies change
in status or position between Regina
Mahindra and that fear of group status
being reversed of these supposedly
age-old hierarchies being upended is a
classic trigger for mass violence and
particularly so when that group is kin
foreign who whose interests whose
cultures belief systems are deeply odds
with profess indigenous groups and there
are a few other periods in a country's
political development that better allow
for this potential change in status
between groups than democratization
given the enfranchising effect that it
supposedly has and so this might be why
the cause for the expulsion of the
reinjure are being voiced as loudly by a
self-styled Democrats as anyone else
because the military's campaign is seen
to be in defense of nascent democracy
whose fruits or whose gains are
understood to be limited in that logic
ridding the country of this competing
group would make others better able to
prosper if they remain than the federal
status of the recline or others in a
change in society would be eroded so we
have democratization in Myanmar has
almost a zero-sum game and therefore a
potentially perilous venture and less
rival groups like the reinjure who have
feared to be competing for limited
rights and resources are constrained or
as we've seen now expelled from the
country and this I think helps to
explain why the military is now seen in
the public eye to be acting defensively
not aggressively both because we hinge
are believed to be threatening to those
who claim the nation for themselves and
the democratization is also threatening
unless it's executed very carefully five
minutes
and this reframing since 2012 of you
know who the reinjure are as a kind of
single unit of nefarious intent as meant
that there's no disaggregation of the
individual from the group and that's
provided a very powerful foundation for
the kind of public support we've seen
for a campaign
ethnic cleansing it's also why we have
this acute polarity between the
international community and the local
community in terms of how violence is
interpreted the international community
see a marauding army attacking and
defenseless population the domestic
constituency in Miyama or at least the
large cross-section of it appears to see
the military acting defensively and I
think that kind of throws up how neurons
how complex the situation is in the
country because what's driving is this
violence isn't merely deep-seated
prejudices the military cultivated this
idea that were anyone free to make claim
on the nation and were all groups to be
enfranchised then those who are really
deserving of democratic gains would lose
out and it had quietly hinted the
democratization could be a perilous
venture and I think we're seeing the
results of the fears that that produced
been exercised now just a quick final
point to bring this into the present as
well as the need to gain a much more
deeper understanding of the context to
all this I think we now need to pay very
close attention to what's happening in
the country the future for northern
reclines state and particularly the
demands being voiced by various
governments for the repeal tration of
the revenger without really
understanding what they might go back to
the military strategy appears to be one
of forcible population transfer from
what we know of its past behavior this
will this clearance operation will allow
it to essentially reorganize the social
and security landscape of a kind' state
and it's historically used campaigns
against ethnic minorities as a way to
reject its power in two parts of the
country where it's felt lacking and as a
means to better able better control and
administer populations
it's only been three months since this
latest campaign began but already we're
seeing plans been laid by the government
and the military that pushed this idea
of a kind of reclamation or
recolonization of what was ruined your
land and the government has already said
the the land on which we hinge of
villages once stood will become the
property of the state range of crops
that were left by flame range will be
harvested by the state and redistributed
amongst the local population which is
now predominantly Buddhist and that
Ranger who are allowed to return will be
placed in what appears to be a
repatriation camp that was announced
this morning actually and I think we all
fear the fees will essentially be
replicas of the internment camps the
Ranger have been confined to for five
years now elsewhere in the state but
while there's an effort to contain and
gradually weaken the Ranger there's also
what seems to be an effort to expand the
presence of Buddhists in what was a
ranger dominated area and in the early
90s the military began a program to
resettle Buddhists in model villages in
northern reclines state in a bid to
break up the Muslim community and to
provide evidence that this is in fact
Buddhist land and I guess you could draw
a parallel with the Israeli settlement
project in the West Bank so an effort to
essentially colonized land by
incentivizing people to relocate there
and actually a couple of years ago
Joanne and I traveled to northern
recline state and we found some of these
model Buddhist villages some of whom
were composed entirely of homeless
people from Yangon or former prisoners
who had been given early release in
exchange for relocating to northern
reclined state and they were gifted a
house they were gifted a cow land to
till
as part of this colonization drive and
since August this year the government
has mooted the idea of extending this
network of Buddhist villages likely on
the sites of burn or hinder villages and
there's an evident conviction that this
land must be taken back from her hinder
that there must be this demographic
engineering to prove that it's Buddhist
land and the cleansing effectively
provides space for it to do this the
land has to be cleaned before it can be
reborn and I'll just quote the recline
state's secretary who said recently and
he'll be a chief player in what happens
in recline state from now on he said
recently of the range of the quote
unquote this is not their land they are
not the real owners zona is the nation
our ancestors we will never give them
away so I think this efforts take back
the cleansed areas of reclined state
speaks to the fact that we can't view
what's happened over the past three
months as an isolated campaign as a
response to a trigger event but as part
of a much longer strategy and the years
of demonization of the reinjure their
construction as a threat has I think
been vital to building public support
for what is essentially a campaign of
state expansion and particularly so now
because they've been framed as a threat
to the limited Democratic gains that are
available in Myanmar
I think it's vital that we take this
bigger picture this long view going
forward when we analyze exactly what's
been happening and where things are
likely to go because I think it enables
us to see it as part of a larger state
crafted project and without that we miss
a fundamental part of the bigger picture
so I'll end on that very pessimistic
note
[Applause]
Thank You Francis um
Cho sideline who's a rare kind activist
who works at interfaith and youth issues
is going to speak now about some of his
experiences hello let me introduce
family - Joseph
I'm from Northern Rock I stay I born
there I grew up there
so I ran the organization and that
organization promotes social harmony and
yes human rights awareness so myself
also say aids political prisoner I was a
silent island colonies and the
Columbia's Island and then looking at
Memory Walk what happened in my city sir
so I would like to to highlight two
things I will say like related with a
friend sesqui as was the the framings
said the family what they're talking
about so when I live in Rakhine so like
we can say we can study together we can
play two gases empty 2012 and we don't
have much that I we don't like for life
for child or for lies student so we
don't see any TV like differences we can
go aloud together but I think the
problem is a family or the problem with
the people who are elique they are
generating the term right in the disco
so in 2012 I was there and recently like
2006 sexting attack also 2017 August I
was there in Dalton Rock high stakes so
what happened my organization 2000 after
2017 or gas attack
so the who our operation have to
postpone and the offices are closed down
also so so now so also there likes as a
rock I in the international community
like we are like really there
and we are a cancer ruin girl so this
also like allows us to rock I had this
also like anti cero hinges that disco so
I would like to highlight why say we had
this kind of the disco so like say I
wanted to say about the like second wall
wall there roaming just are aligned with
the British and British give them the
favor and then and then sir
Rock I artists and power so lights and
so sorry - very angry and then sir when
the Japanese came to Dharma or Akai and
Japanese favourite rock I and that this
empower to the raw Incas so during that
tide had lobster light mass violence and
mass atrocity so the Wonder and Wonder
second world war like rock Isla push out
to the now southern Sierra high stay and
when the Japanese can and rock I push
back to the raw anger and the decay mass
atrocity and they pushed and Northern
Rock ice tanks so now the demography
Buddhist our South not in the Muslims
Rohingya under unless in the also in the
respected also the memories in certain
90s 1946 the ruin just say in science
group they are they warning they would
like to dry the northern rock high state
with a East Pakistan
Athens for a high that is a beating and
also a second time post-independence
the ruins is a Mujahideen movement and
they are they are asking the
independence tank so I think that two
things is a big matter for the naxaiites
tank because it requires all way their
their vdr grievance X because because
the British are taken by masking are
taken they are land so they have this
kind of say
grievance X and ins 2012 Armenia pile
2006 things attacked and mm something or
the recent attack that is a Impala Qaeda
it's like we have to the protect our
land and the rominger are taking to our
land and this is like that and that is
the interstate media as well as like
government officer and Academy they are
generating these characters ideas so
they Rock I so cool and then they don't
trust anybody and also there is no like
accountabilities what happens
Craven sex in 2012 what happens in the
second world war what happened in there
in the arouser alleys they're 80 and mr.
roving just also they feel the same
thing so there's no accountability they
arcade alpha on the country and they are
in the Bangladesh in the camp and
soulless people like and the government
never take any accountability so what
happened 2002 and 500,000 sexting what
happened to thousands something's that
the conflict is escalating so even
though they are repeat right back again
I think there will be more like big
actual Sufi coming because we haven't we
don't we don't have any comfort ability
so that is like why I would like to
highlight the current Thank You Joseph
and we can speak more about your
experiences during the Q&A as well um
next we'll have um your win who will
talk about his organization's work on
interfaith dialogue that pertains for
inter crisis and beyond
thank you very much giving me the
opportunity in his this very important
panel with very famous specialists I
just want to highlight you know why we
started to work for this kind of social
cohesion social harmony so-called
interfaith harmony we used attempt and
also our organization of trying to prize
for the voiceless that's why we are
involved in organ joy issue we are
involved LGBT issue inside Burma we are
human right based organization we are
involving the citizenship issue because
of citizenship also very complexity in
Burma one of the writers in Burma who
used the term family sedition law
so-called 1982 sedition law easy to be
stainless very difficult to be citizens
so anybody including our state council
our current our icons tall sounds very
easy to be a stainless I come to the law
whoever wanted by the you know military
even American easy to be Burma citizen
because if they have positioned me so me
there is no proper mechanism I think so
based on the fact factual so just want
to do that's why we are involved in
citizen issue particular for non porous
people who are challenges for students
even though they live several many
generations live in Burma but they were
suffering because of the end of Buddhist
so I mean that why this you know ethanol
religious nationalism promise specialist
battle in I use new nationalism Obama
forever use that's definitely they are
appetite policy already predicted
practiced in Burma that's why we are
started to raise this issue since 2000
around there so because we notice hey
specious not so new so-called dangerous
place is not so new I just wanted to
narrate you know little bit the
background of the recent crisis how
anti-ro hinder move move
shifted to anti Muslims and already
spread our anti-christian as well in
some area not only that anti-muslim or
anti-christian you can see aunty I and
you empty NGO and tu an
that kind of certain man already
established if you go outside the
Rangoon somebody said I'm working in NGO
that that guy may be betraying the
country that guy maybe the terrible
enemy of the state
that kind of past but the people already
established that's a very dangerous for
their situation so I noticed since 1989
after recoup the country in 98 a one of
the book it is threat our country wise
started back in 1989 to call so call in
Burmese I'm not really proper
translation in in in English but he used
in good very translation for the one of
the slogan of immigration very good you
know that's very difficult to translate
into English like like a new plasma so
jasja that I like to trying to translate
like we are fearing or worrying to lose
our race and religion that kind of bow
at the time another military period
under the military administration you
cannot be a published even in single
leaflet or pamphlets so those times the
Buddhist spread out all over Burma
nobody take accountability so in around
993 nine it for that country widespread
out that book even in some area in
Mandalay we notice Mandalay is Meryl
Obama one of the former police before
the colonial so even a wedding people
went to the wedding
so they give as a gift wedding gift for
dead book who came to the wedding so
that kind of situation thousands or
thousands of boats are spread all over
Burma nobody takes accountability where
is intelligent this body not official
book
we don't know who published so bad that
boats are already angry there how
Muslims are terrible
how Muslim are trying to
the land how Muslim are you know making
the you know missionary marry with them
with full wife or kid but a lot of
children something like that kind of a
speech or dangerous or you know such a
man or you know how terrible way of you
know like Muslim like conquer like
Indonesia
well that Buddhist land now its Muslim
majority land Afghanistan was Buddhist
land you know so CO and and factual to
it to be honest no reference but they
give a lot of reference so that God has
felt out nine ninety three ninety four
countrywide so in ninety six we are
noticed group of people oh that would
invade danger in the future that may be
making the problem be problem instead
country so we are trying to write the
letter to the minister at that time the
so-called religious Minister Chan left
in their general new new you at that
time so at that time I only received
this letter somebody you know took his
Rick and his signatory and his name
mentioned
they call him how you got in this book
how you got the information he said
complaining the guy who who are the
supposed to write to them in front of
them so means they're not taking action
for the people who are spread in this
book they taken the guy who write please
take care of this situation will be very
soon maybe a bit problem coming so that
person has to be threatened so that we
notice in but practically they studied
997 I noticed nine ninety a some area in
Rangoon some area in Mandalay some area
in prong we copy
attack to Muslims but I was at the time
very young so we are group of ghent
group who are trying to collect the
information and give in oh is coming in
Krupa monk or group of people so
something like that so we are trying to
engage so that time so we noticed that
situation so in 2000 around 2000 we are
started to raise awareness about for
interfaith tolerance issue we should
study to work for this issue without
people awareness of these things if it
to be a you know per se this kind
racist movement for the future our
country may be the ugliest ugly face
now really started already for ugly
situation in the country people used to
say one of our decay bombers people very
nice promise to be very good nature but
I had now no more because of this
resistance already hegemony test course
so that we have started to work about
that so mean I mean that's a narrated
already so I around 2000 I went to some
place like in I met one of the military
high ranking officer he already retired
I got a chance to speak with him he just
shared he just called a sure he said I
was in you know some area in Burma you
know in I'm in charge of some area like
some border area no not the Riccar
southern area one of the our top
military psychosocial wall people from
the psychosocial world came to us and
trained something like propaganda one of
the KY lecturers took about the
propaganda black black way of propaganda
Brown way or propaganda something like
teacher like that he talked about that
Brown way of propaganda for another like
we published a book like a new trauma so
jasja that's the fearing we looted loose
recently we published he just said like
him he gonna show that book project of
ours you know
so means that he shared with me that so
means that are they are very
systematically you know pre-planned
well-planned London making the tension
you know a trust you know you know that
kind of so that's not recent so under
the name of the democratization you know
they are trying to keep their power the
people who are wanted to keep the power
so they are trying to make it some
problem so that unfortunate fortunately
I think the Muslim are the tacit
that's rock India are the most easiest
sky coping community that that is one of
the target there secondly the general
Muslim they already hate make Hank
hatred for Muslim because of this book
other book like you know different book
already straight up so that's our
initial state to us arguing that and now
that's even a Muslim in mainland it
they're not so safe to live very skull
face girl
so not only Muslim but also you know
they thought that after this maybe in
Christian maybe maybe in others you know
country have to be very so no more
democratization process are going on so
to be under the name of so-called
nationalism so-called defending or
protection or race and religion so
that's our really non very very unique
situation that's why we are organization
or the trying to do something you know
interface you program you know and also
the human right wellness program
particular focus on religious freedom
freedom of religion of beliefs are
already corny bomb I think because where
I born that the township all Methodists
are shut off by the racist crew cave
authority are no protection you know so
means that kind of the situation
happening you know some area in current
stay in the Christian Church campus
policeman came he dreamed let's not go
that is the place of Buddhist something
like the Babri Masjid in India so and
then okay so and then so he took the
land and build the pagoda off mostly
nobody take accountability where is the
law this is a church Christian Church
campus to build the coda without
approval of this Christian community so
first to do it everything so means you
know religious tolerance you know not so
much so city of you know diversity even
I got a shot less I will conclude this I
got a shot you know the when I was to go
into South and northern Shan State one
of the lady she is
in the civil society community she just
shared me she came to Rangoon less three
weeks ago to attend some meeting
sometime I have free time I explode to
the staudte
she said come down a lot of Muslim day a
lot of mas day so that's I noticed now
how Muslim are you know taking position
in the country she she said like that I
got and I also got a shot once she that
kind of information said to me she's not
aware and boom let go Shengo seems
establishment of British in night 18 you
know 50 those people are 99%
subpopulation are Indian mix and Indian
people to be honest so look now after
the 1964 nationalization a lot of
burmese buddhist also present there
almost 30% now in this toronto area so
she not aware of that because she got
everyday the peer pressure and you know
this this you know propaganda by they
you know when cited information so she
not so much aware about city centre of
Rangoon so she suddenly she saw that a
lot of Muslim a lot of moss oh there is
new thing like that you know rock I old
not only in Rakhine but also even in
Rangoon we are so you know worried for
that so I shared that no this is like
that so it means that's of how dangerous
you know not only Harbor also many
people like that kind of discourse that
it had EE disco already threw up the
country all print media all you know I
can say 99.999 print media you know and
also the politicians they are also
driving the same way already shot your
son already mentioned that you know so
that's a real current situation you know
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
taking your win and now say Shui o or
Jim Scott well thank you very much I'm I
think the least best least and best
informed in terms of the history of the
Roja so I'm going to be both brief and
I'm trying to save time for a number of
people in the audience who know a lot
more about this issue than I and who
want to have a chance to talk about it
the I wanted to echo mule wins point
that I suppose you are saying in one way
or another that in the famous German
rendition of this first they came for
the Muslims but I wasn't a Muslim then
they came for the Christians and I
wasn't a Christian then they came right
for the Zoroastrians and I wasn't a
Zoroaster and then they came for me so
one might ask I think in in general
crumbs of why the role indra one could
as easily claim and there are lots of
groups ethnic groups in Burma that spill
across borders historically why couldn't
one say that the Mun are actually ties
and why the hell are they on Burmese
soil why couldn't one say that that's
true for a lot of the Quran as well why
are the Shands not considered ties and
part of that is an effort by the
military and the state to claim that the
most extensive borders of of the state
I'm not going to spend any time today on
the on the questions that I made lots of
people I think which is should there
were hinge be citizens except to notice
that the borders of Burma when they were
fixed at the moment of independence
actually included the old a home kingdom
conquered by the Berman's as a
concession to the Berman's and that's
why
it included lots of real India in the
national boundaries of Burma the
revenge' of course were eligible to vote
and did vote in the 2010 constitutional
referendum an addition of course and I
wonder how on some sushi deals were this
on a daily basis there are thousands and
thousands of our India who were
militants and went to prison on behalf
of the NLD and the democracy movement in
Burma and who were now declared to be
outside of the Burmese nation and
outside of citizenship if revenge are to
be citizens reasonable people can debate
the process by which that citizenship
might be determined but in this respect
it's worth mentioning that most of the
proposals provide for the proving by
documentation of residence and history
when in fact one of the consequences are
not the only cause of the last ethnic
cleansing is that most of the revenger
have no documentation in law and
couldn't prove the first thing about
their their history the I think whoever
the most important thing immediately is
the question of human rights not whether
the revenger our citizens and which will
injure our citizens but in addition as
we have pointed out to the ethnic
cleansing that has been going on since
1970 over time this immediate crisis of
more than half a million people burned
out chased out murdered
and their livelihoods and residences
destroyed its I want to emphasize we're
talking about more than a half a million
people this is probably the biggest
ethnic cleansing since the Second World
War
it's an extraordinary event and despite
efforts by the international community
and NGOs and so on it actually is an
event that is much less prominent in our
consciousness and in our newspapers than
it deserves to be that has a lot to do
with the history of reporting on Burma
in the first place the I actually
actually believe that this event will
cast an historical dark shadow over the
Burmese nation for the next half century
or more I think this is an event for
Burma comparable to the Turks having to
deal with the Armenian Genocide with the
Indonesians having to deal with the
massacres of 200,000 and more people
after the 1965 generals coup with the
what the Hutu having to deal with the
extermination of Tutsi in Rwanda I think
this will stain the nationhood and
reputation of Burma in a way that
Burmese historians and ethical thinkers
in the next half century or a century
will have to some come to terms with as
now it's being it's being buried so it's
a great stain on the Burmese nation that
I think whether they deal with it sooner
or later it will be a large boulder in
the middle
of the understanding of what the Burmese
nation even if it becomes a democratic
nation represents and it seems to me
that a I understand that the Democrats
who I admire many of my friends are
desperately concerned that a split on
the revenger issue will derail the slow
progress toward democracy and they're
afraid to jeopardize the chance that
also Sochi sees for a new constitution
which will minimize the influence and
power of the military to block civilian
legislation the but this is not only a
negation of responsibilities but what
kind of democracy can be built on the
basis of this enormous historical denial
of the basis of Burmese nationhood
and and unity it's a terrible foundation
on which to build a democracy and it is
I think a desperately dangerous
demonstration of the institutional
impunity of the military that having
successfully mobilized militia and the
military to essentially victimize for
the most part an innocent population
this entrenches the military's impunity
historically and into the future and my
own feeling and my own doubts about
democratization is that even if one
imagines that over a 10-year period the
period in the process of democratization
was successful what has actually been
happening on the ground and this is an
addition
- Francis's talking about West Bank and
things on the ground
the military has over the past many
years been seizing land from peasants
seizing enterprises grabbing hotels
making titles to property over to
themselves organizing concessions for
Chinese and Thai enterprises and Burmese
enterprises medicines say they have been
seizing most of the valuable physical
assets of Burma and so I ask myself even
if the transition to democracy is
successful after ten years what's going
to be left to save because everything
will be titled over to military
commanders and their entourage and the
people and in a p-dog I think that the
task for historical sociology and
students of culture is to understand how
this hatred came to be in the first
place and to say there's no doubt that
it's it's not simply a figment of the
military's imagination and come that is
they have the act they have come to be
able to rely on the act of complicity
and support of the population in general
and the fact is I think as you know Wynn
referred to the prejudice toward the
revenge' is an exaggerated version of a
prejudice in general toward Muslims long
before any of this began I was always
shocked when the question of the
muslimah came up and my Burmese friends
would talk about the danger for Muslims
and the and here what struck me is the
gendered aspect of this fear and
hysteria
this the what was often said to me is
they Muslims
are stealing our women as if we own
these women and they're only available
to us right and so it seemed to me to be
a kind of a scary about loss of culture
and religion that was particularly
exaggerated among males and one might
argue among some of the clergy as well
who've been propagating this for a long
long time it's not it's not new in in
Burmese culture and there have been
attacks I'm sure people could have many
other places on Muslims in MEC Tula and
lush oh and will you mine in Mandalay in
Rangoon Yangon and and so on so this is
the Muslims in general and in fact
Hindus don't also live in a kind of
constant fear that they may come under
these attacks as well and so we have
over the past 30 years a combustible
material has built up such that a spark
of accusation of rape by role in German
can set off a huge congregation so it's
actually not interesting what is the
particular spark just as it wasn't
interesting in the 1960s in the urban
riots in Detroit and so on to ask what
particular police stopping a black man
resulted in the riot the question is how
did the combustible material develop
over a long period of time such that a
spark would be able to set off a sort of
huge congregation and that seems to me
to be the kind of question that one has
to historically ask because unless you
understand how it got created you can't
understand how it might be undone
rectified and mitigated it's to ask how
this combustible material was assembled
how it was reinforced structurally
historically how it's actively aided by
a military propaganda of course how the
projection of the Buddhist state to the
actual physical boundaries is part of a
national project this is by the way
something that's happened elsewhere in
Southeast Asia as well transmigration
and Indonesia is an effort to take
Javanese populations and to put them in
the outer islands where they are seen to
be more loyal to Jakarta and the central
government to take Vietnamese lowland
populations and replace Hill populations
along the Chinese border with loyal kin
Vietnamese people in Vietnamese
ethnicity so this is in a sense in part
a kind of strategic problem as well and
the question then is why there Andrew
why the Muslims and to end I guess I
think it's it's not as if the United
States doesn't have a lot of historical
ethnic cleansing and genocide to answer
for I might add but it seems to me that
the demonization of Islam by the United
States and by American political leaders
in which Islam equals Muslim and Muslim
Isis equals Islam and Islam equals Isis
has provided a kind of international
authorization and certification for the
amplification of these prejudices and so
the world campaign against Isis and the
way in which it is coded indirectly
religious terms rather than terrorist
terms is partly responsible for this
hysteria and the capacity to amplify it
among the Burmese population
[Applause]
okay thank you we're gonna segue into a
question and answer or discussion rather
their mics on either side as people line
up I'm going to invoke the prerogative
of a chair and ask a couple questions
for the panel that they can consider I
guess the first would be that I think
some of the arguments you here are that
democracy has unleashed animosities that
were all already there and I wonder what
slips in behind or comes along with
democracy in the sense of the military
as it started to prepare for this
liberalisation did what Jim mentioned
which was start stealing the nation's
resources liberalizing land markets so
that when they owned the land then they
could sell it off land became no longer
used for production necessarily because
it became worth more to sit idle and to
be sold off as a investment resource
than it would to produce rice for
instance and so I wonder to what extent
to some of this violence is it a product
of a precarity felt by dispossessed
peasants who are no longer provided for
they will no longer provide of her way
of producing and contributing to the
nation and are told well instead of you
know being a good Burmese person by
producing rice you can guard the
contours of this nation by literally
policing its borders the second question
would be the one about a one about race
or one about difference more broadly
because on one hand what's really
interesting about Myanmar and
anthropologists who have studied this
have noted it for 100 years is how
ethnicity is a performance that
is inscribed through stuff like what you
wear how you speak whether you can know
a little bit about religion and one of
the really fascinating parts about
Francis's book is a chapter on a person
he calls along so I believe who longs so
maybe who goes from being more Hindu to
being Buddhist and he fakes it and he
ends up making it on so there's a sense
that if you do it the right way if you
act the right way it doesn't matter what
you are underneath there is no
underneath and yet on the other hand
thiagão said oh uh probably the most
famous monk in the country and one that
the United States diplomats and NGOs
have made the very foolish mistake of
backing for a long time got in front of
the military last week and said that
killing anyone who is in Buddhist is not
a crime you can slaughter as many as you
want he invoked the past histories of
Buddhist kings supposedly doing this
then he stepped back and said I'm not
necessarily saying that but he was
saying so we have two different
discourses of race or a difference that
exist side-by-side and that's fine I
mean we in America know how confused we
can be about our own narratives and our
own politics and hold those two ideas or
many different ideas in your head at
once but I what I asked this for is to
lead to a third question the annoying
question that I you probably are fearing
which is well where do we go from here
what kind of solutions can we think of
after you've heard a pretty bleak
description of the scenarios I'm sorry
of the circumstances and this isn't to
force solutions where they don't exist I
think it's sometimes important to just
be upfront about things and say things
are bleak and it'll take a lot of work
but what might that work look like
[Music]
I'm gonna dodge the first question the
second wasn't really a question but you
talk about ethnicity as performance I
think certainly there's this idea in
Miyama
as there is elsewhere that you have
fixed group of groups of peoples that
unchanging across time as if they sort
of rose up from the ground as one and
that's pitched against this idea of
Ranger has been very much a kind of
construct something that came about very
recently as part of this political
project that I spoke of and it's men I
mean that's the sort of I guess this
idea of fixed group groups is or one
whole body is sort of foundation of
nationalist thinking and it presupposes
that there is one unit of us and then
the scattering of them and that we have
always been one nation and this is the
idea that I think our military has tried
to put forward over the past 40 50 years
or so is that we have this long lineage
in the country we know who you are we
know who our people are there are these
sort of external or internal
contaminants in that project they need
to be read from the country but from
what I found and what other people have
found certainly and the work of leach is
that ethnic boundaries very porous they
move around a lot people can move
between ethnicities so this idea that an
ethnic group and ethnic identity is
fixed doesn't read they're up to the
empirical evidence people become another
ethnicity when that process of becoming
least enfranchisement and
happened across Burma and the person
that Elliott referenced who I dedicated
a whole chapter 2 in the book is range a
guy who grew up near booty down moved to
Yangon when he was younger
realized that if he kept hold if he sort
of stayed true to the range identity
publicly at least then he wouldn't be
able to get a job he wouldn't be able to
progress in life so he fudged his
ethnicity on his ID card which after the
70s everyone had to have vestnik
designator on their ID card that allowed
him to enter the army I'd only give away
the story you should buy the book he got
into the army and then he was taken to
then he professed his belief in Buddhism
that he was no longer a Muslim and he
became a functionary in the religious
department the Ministry of Religious
Affairs overseen the conversions of
hilltribe people from Christianity to
Buddhism there's this huge irony within
that the next question where to from
here I mean I think first and foremost
there needs to be a deeper understanding
of the complexities of the crisis the
complexities of the factors that are
motivating the violence both from a kind
of strategic point from the military why
they want to snap and how they can
profit from this but also how these
prejudices have been generated it's not
just a sudden not a sudden eruption that
emerged from you know very little is a
condition that's been developed across
decades and the Ranger haven't been the
only victim there are these sort of I
suppose tears of belonging in Myanmar
and they equal or they often result in
prejudices
even amongst people who are considered
indigenous in the country so there'll be
Burma who resents the sort of hill
peoples for example who they don't know
particularly well I've never really been
incorporated into the sort of main body
of the nation-state and this has created
a landscape in which ethnic identities
are incredibly volatile and so
international approaches so far or
international responses to the crisis
over the past few months have been more
I guess material in nature so talk of
sanctioning the military or talk from
the government in Miyama
of funding the development of reclines
they as a kind of remedy for communal
tensions or to placate placate recline
at least without much understanding of
what lies beneath all of this and I
think first and foremost people need to
your one needs to kind of get to grips
with that and develop this right deep
understanding that's the first thing
then I suppose gives some sort of hope
that one day we might be able to kind of
untangle what's happening and find some
sort of remedy but yeah I do echo
Elliott's sense that things are very
bleak there's heavy pressure on
Bangladesh on me a mug of them to accept
Ranger back what they returned to could
be as perilous as their current
condition if not worse if they are
pushed into these repatriation camps
they will likely be interred there for
god knows how many years and the
communal dynamic in recliners they is
now so toxic that were there beat we're
there to be another trigger for violence
such as another attack by the insurgents
which is very likely then that will
provide another excuse for the military
to sweep in and do you know finish up
the job that they started more recently
someone else oh yeah please I will tend
the stain to prerogative as a holder of
Burmese our passport to talk about where
we can go from here
so Elliott started out by saying that
the tyranny of the of the map and I
would add that we have multiplicity of
tremors package and burdens you know on
us in over many centuries and and some
of them it's codified by the
intellectual policy of some British
surveyors particularly by failure who
came up with 135 raises and so I said
that because when we started
democratization period it is
unfortunately became it became the
framework to to to take the country from
there so for example in 2014 census we
were asked to choose you know which race
or ethnicity we belong to a lot of
advisors to the UN and also countries
that were behind the 75 million dollar
project advised the government not to
post that question because it is so
problematic
we just had 2012 riots in Rakhine know
now we are asking how we should identify
myself in Afghanistan they omitted that
question it was no own census we could
easily do the same but we were imposed
so and then that created a lot of
problems no they were rallying behind
people who wanted to honor define
destroy hinges and also catch in worried
that if they identified as a subgroup of
Cochino they will be divided up so there
was rallying behind getting people to
under find a sketchy and not the
circular vodka chains and the Shan State
it was the opposite people enjoyed an
area to the area they wrote down 914 the
other or dying it because if they wanted
to they don't want 200 find as a
maintian group so what I was saying is
that we had a lot of historical baggage
and they are that the trauma and the
didn't probably go through
decolonization Dima literalization now
the whole democratization process is
upon us and there is only one model that
we should follow right including the
census because the way to understand and
interpret the wall is to data right we
need these kind of data and fast but it
backfire after three years that
ethnicity or racial data haven't been
published yet so what a waste of the 75
million but they claim that they use the
data for any for other projects and the
other thing is that I would say they
inked finger democratization process so
they take the purposes of democratic
decision or people could vote now we
have the elections so it was all rosy
and you know of feeling fee good and I
remember writing us letters to
newspapers like Financial Times oh so
you think that democratization period
infirm is over now we have the real
democracy because they ignore what is
going or they did it take the balance of
what they made army was not doing where
they're not killing anymore
right because under the democratization
period we stay hard army killing in
Kachin State
if the army ignoring all their Oh
companies doing the mining now the whole
village was covered with schools and
everything and so it was all
conveniently ignored and I said the
other week
the Western media disappointment and
also the west disappointment nonsense DG
is a diversion away from disappointment
in themselves because they are world
viewed and what I will call and the the
the the worldview and the policies are
single-handedly shaped by her right so
now they're saying the odious did then
sir since 2010 and since 2012 they were
ignoring all those little voices like
like the works that they were doing when
they talk to you and I mean we would say
oh why are you so pessimistic you know
the country is not that bad you know we
shouldn't do that you know we should
focus and then redriver
our energy to institutionalization this
is the big ones that they like to use so
I think the worst also has to share some
blame in it and then she's like it's
it's again convenient for them to just
blame you know the country and and also
the the Frances talk about binary view
and I will add that and also Burmese
society and also people living in the
country has been view s victims know so
we it's true that we have no long
colonia history and their socialism and
you know militarization but we are able
to claim our moral autonomy right and it
is only one we could claim our more
autonomy and have moral clarity to say
are things you know what is going on you
know as it is instead of living in
denial instead of living if you are
against Muslim if you are a cancer in
there you are no Berman's and so if
people could start live living out of
their fear or if if we have more people
like whom your win or good choice I
think this is this is a hope and and
that these people have to be encouraged
and supported not just you know select a
few groups or people you know to support
I will say that
Thanks um we have a lot of people who
want to ask questions so let's take a
couple let's start with Jared sure thank
you to all the panelists for your
insightful analysis of this really
horrible conflict my my question is to
what extent can we see what's unfolding
in reclined state in relationship with
the seventy years of civil war that have
been going on in the country and
instances of violence against other
ethnic minorities the current National
Union just released a statement saying
we regret to see the repeat of history
in northern reclined state drawing a
parallel between the attacks and massive
displacement on current civilians over
the past decades and and so I'm
wondering to what extent can that sort
of parallels between conflicts and
different parts of the countries and
form our understanding of what's
happening in northern our kind
yeah I just relate the thank you
my deeper questions were actually
already hit on so I'll ask a briefer
question that's more direct um for the
gentleman on the far left you yes thank
you thank you you mentioned that there
was a lack of accountability between
people between tribes or groups of
people leading up to the violence that
we see today and I was just curious if
you could explain in a little more
detail what you mean by lack of
accountability in that sense and then
you also mentioned a lack of
accountability from the part of the
military so I'm curious how these types
of accountability differ again thank you
all very much for the work that you do
and first being I just I had a
particular question about the manner in
which these atrocities have been taking
place as you all were speaking the kind
of technocratic separation that exists
here I think the the comparison that was
made to the Holocaust in Nazi Germany
is something that rang out to me
particularly strongly especially in this
story about the woman that had that had
no idea that there was a Muslim
population in the capital city I thought
that was very similar to Himmler and the
trains but but thinking about I guess
thinking about that and going back to a
question that was asked kind of
rhetorically earlier do we see I guess
in your opinion is the democratization a
similar kind of mechanism that is being
used in separation from the people or I
guess by the military generals or other
people that are enacting this work is
that kind of being used as a way to push
her in this violence in a manner that
kind of that separates the people from
from the actual act of the violence
itself or is democratization kind of
secondary to this is it is it in concert
with the violence that is occurring
is it simply the backdrop yeah those
those three that's those three questions
with our trajectories or connections
with longer histories of violence and
counterinsurgency and then the question
of accountability and how that
influences society and then this third
question about democratization and it's
enabling factors or is it is it just a
background of what's going on I think
the process already went dead and Matt
was already branded you know some kind
of impunity issue is relating with this
accountability issue because impunity a
lot of atrocities have done and Sabra
here nobody even a constitution not
allowed to do
revenge of the two two to favor for the
trial but even it currently until today
stay impunity and keep going on the you
know atrocities in different ways so
that I would like to say I'm just so
much not too much focus on the atrocity
issue because I live in Bama that have
to be a favor me did not too much
criticizing for this critical trustee
because of my security and I also not
another issue is like democratization of
course the the awareness of democracy is
really really very weak I think
government although nothing to do any
awareness of democracy and human drama
people in Burma who understood the
democracy means the majority will yes of
course democracy's maturity will that
they thought that in this room maybe six
people are sitting together fat people
thought that these people are dangerous
we should kill him
five people thought this pretender we
should kill him so that majority were
too
that kind of awareness weekend the whole
bomber we don't want rope India we don't
want Muslim that majority wait that's
why our top top people they don't want
to speak up
no just it Andrew Salah I want to say
too much about the root cellar issue as
but because a lot of rules and another
loss of habitat you know so you see even
in you know accomplishing that the based
on the law already discriminated already
problematic you know so means the
another things I of course the another
thing is like compared with the no more
applies the already mentioned about the
even is some influential clergy talking
about very like you know supporting for
this kind of atrocity that mean nobody
like a stronger people no more requests
came out for defending for minority for
defending for the people are suffering
or terrorize so that's we are notice
that that's why the few people I'd like
to highlight some time you know kind of
the human right defenders issue as well
that correctly linkage with that evenly
you know Facebook are really problematic
so-called social media particulars for
spoke so so people are trust if you - oh
I know from the Facebook news something
like that so actually Facebook is not
news
but they don't know that all facebook
news online news
so that are really really really
propagate you know that's why the anti
Roja hysteria has now spread out to
become an anti Muslim like I already
mentioned this but to say like human
rights defender who talked about for
just yet who talked about for human
rights they also end a threat that's
also another issue you know that's
without that few be murdered offend are
also talking about this issue as well
even a difference from humor a defender
in this issue always
silent so because not only our moral
leadership are silent but also a lot of
so-called humor at the front are human
like activates they are they also silent
a man in the civil society is what this
issue is very controversial nobody
wanted to touch SoCo under the terms
they used a sensitive so called
we used in almost picture sensitive so
nobody touch it that's why this issue
bigger and bigger you know I'd like to
focus on the accountability issues you
know that means nobody take a
responsibility that that is that is my
pathetic on there so even now it also
how can I say in English like pushing
more each other
Oh somebody said this is the
respondibility for so-called energy
government somebody say or not this is
not responsibility for them this is the
military responsibility who is the
responsibility the people are suffering
people are terrorized people are dealing
this is a human right crisis no time to
debate for the ethnic of brahma or not
or they are citizens of brahma or not
that's kind of issue
no no bitwise no like inferential person
came up and talked about and i notice in
indonesia in transition like against the
christian some point that time you know
like I noticed the of the Raman why he
later he took as a presidential power he
after the he stepped off he took a stand
up for the moderate wise no we have to
protest for these our fellow Christians
so mean like that no person like him in
Burma came up yet that even though these
so-called inferential clergy talk about
oh this is no sin who are killing none
none Buddhist so like I never had this
kind of discourse and this kind of
narrated for Buddhists for this is based
on peace love compassionate and
appreciate that's based on the Buddhism
thank you very much that's my response
yeah I would say like you know Lord is
is like is that misused by the
policymaker
especially our Sun Tzu she she always
say Rudo a law and then the problems
that we have is security forces and
judiciary Department are the weakest
institution in in Burma but also like
less people are only spoken on the
policy making but the implementation of
policy is very lacking so that's why I
love Sur law-breaking
are happening if you look at their look
at the single cases like in 2014 NGO
office where attacked in my city and I
see us or assembly the ICRC office what
I see as his supply war attack and then
this like before that before like occurs
before that before over 25 finest
Rangers attack in such an attack and I
seven Muslim where as an attack and to
maybe one or two we are killed on the
way to the cow and then there's our like
ending single cases there law
enforcement agencies never takes any
accountability and then slides now
currently like myself I have to I have
to afraid us their security forces and
the same time names dieter I think Nancy
I and at the mall and spider who are
really targeted like together like
activists so that's why I think we have
to start a farm like judiciary
Department but the very interesting in
the judiciary Department is controlled
by n LT government and it's not an
administrator by military is
administrating the civilian government
but they never refer on the
implementation so I didn't that's it
that's why so that's why I said the
violin is roughly ting sir constantly
and ins people are exciting to the
violin we can who is coming nice so I
think that is mine
just a couple of things it's interesting
to me the question is who can in a sense
curb the state and historically in Burma
it seems to me there had been aside who
could curb the military when it runs the
state and historically in Burma there
have been only two national forces that
have in a sense provided something of a
break on the military has historically
even in the in the Democratic period one
of them of course is the Buddhist clergy
who were kind of undone during the Navy
wind period by a series of registration
and the effort to control the balloonist
Buddhist clergy at least a good part of
it and then the students whose student
union was dynamited and the distance
learning and the removal of universities
so they were the removal of two forces
and was what was interesting to me in
Erika and Nargis is that rock stars and
their bands and popular figures were
among some of the few people who could
mobilize large groups of people to go
back down and kind of relieve the
suffering from from Nargis I think the
way to start the terrible sad thing
about what's happening in the injured
area is that we have no information
about it
that is to say these are crimes that are
easily hidden and if I compare it to the
history for example of the current human
rights group who for 30 and 40 years
have been collecting information in the
current area general you know or
lieutenant cement came with four people
and Brigade number X stole my cheeks
chickens their pots and pans shot to
another peasant - protested they have
they in a sense if there was ever to be
a process of justice they have the
documentation and the question is is
that proleptic justice does the
collection of this material itself serve
as a kind of mild restraint on what
people actually do if they know that
every move that they take is being
monitored by citizens who care about
human rights and care about what's
happening in all of these places and it
seems to me this is the role of civil
society to have the military understand
that their every move is being watched
and that and that information is being
collected that might be used against
them in future prosecutions I guess an
issue with Rangers that they've got no
functioning civil society in the country
that is winning to represent them or do
the kind of heavy lifting that means
sorry there is no real sort of element
within civil society in Myanmar that's
willing to do this kind of work on the
Ranger so it's left to the
responsibility of groups that are now in
Bangladesh who are taking testimony from
the refugees who've left the country and
the government almost laughably if it
weren't so serious has said that the
exodus of 600,000 people is a kind of an
organized effort to elicit international
sympathy and to tarnish the reputation
of the government itself so it kind of
in almost mocks the stories that the
Ranger being told as it's done for
decades now so on
yeah although someone asked the question
that didn't get answered earlier
gorgeous quickly and how this relates to
other ethnic conflict yeah I think if we
take it as a strategy to on the state's
part to move into that area of northern
reclined state and colonize it and that
certainly happened with other ethnic
conflicts elsewhere in the country as
it's been the case with ceasefires as
well which are also another weapon in
the regime's armory to essentially move
into a region and occupier whether
indirectly or directly and it strikes me
that while a lot of the other ethnic
conflicts elicited broad sympathy
amongst the populace that certainly
hasn't happened in the case of the
Ranger and I think many in Myanmar saw
attacks on other ethnic minorities as a
complete abdication of the state's
responsibility whereas they see attacks
on Ranger as enforcement of that
responsibility because they are
protected against this constructed
threat and I think that's kind of key to
understanding how the military's gained
such support thank you for speed today
and my name is Mary of ischium senior
years police a student from The Ohio
State University so it took me around 20
hours by bus to year today so I'm gonna
ask three questions so so the first one
is related to my teen years is it so man
ask about the role of the UN
humanitarian is enduring with the Hindi
refugee crisis because the humanitarian
is basically just a short term plan for
the to manage your emergency so do you
think the UN Security Council should
politic me is just their own India
crisis to first Miyama government or
even the whole state like thunder - to
come up some actions politically to
ensure the
children just social identity - if the
human rights violation situation and the
second one is according to the census in
2014 so there are over twenty six
percent of people remember they don't
have any ID card so which in fact the
annual number might be even higher as
many people or not not at all surveyed
so as for ninja what makes their social
identity recognize the recognition so
unique comparing with others also don't
have this official identity and the
third question is for for vote Francis
so have you ever been to the added non
conflicted Muslim populated area in real
time so as Chris in dot intensities
televised speech weeks ago she just like
encourage people to come to this area so
do you know the reason why those people
chose to stay in the area
yes thank you well I'm Johnson and I'm a
Burmese American when I talk with
Burmese friends on Facebook they say
that the international media is biased
and that the situation is complex and
you don't understand you American you
come from a different background that
the citizenship here is not like how
Americans to find it and I tell them why
like if you're born in Yemen you should
be no more and how do you promote the
type of civic nationalism and not this
ethnic nationalism that is how do you
broaden the concept of buying that
so Banga means something like stuns of
the soil that if you come from the soil
you belong to the land and if you don't
you don't
and so like how do you change that
concept of kinda into a more broader of
you know we the people like how and well
I think it's a discipline job crisis
this there's an immediate humanitarian
need and there is this long-term that
would take
maybe generations like how do you solve
like the immediate need and the
long-term vision of EMR of what nemuru
memo is
okay I I really thank you for that I
think the role of humanitarian
assistance United Nation that's really
after to tau after August relief 25th
all UN movement ban in the another
account state that's why people are very
suffering there and they have a
different reason to ban for these
missions but a lot of a lot of local
local humanitarian group so-called
humanitarian crew they one day but
practically people so-called Muslims who
are rogue injure or whatever they're not
received any humanitarian system
that's right they are suffering that's
it's their main momentum to push up to
to move to to flap to the Bangladesh
time every day so not only in the
Bangladesh right now a lot of more than
600,000 you know refugees there we are
talking about the repatriation but
nobody think inside work I'm almost 400
thousands are stayed there nobody
consider for those people to so without
the god of food and they God they are
not accessible for livelihood they may
also fled again
so not only for the Bangladesh side of
course we have to care about the the
refugee of their the same we have to
also immediate work for those people but
current trip to our consulate trip to
there may be something little bit
relaxing I think compared with the
previous because international pressure
are also huge pressure so that's why she
one day and you know she kept trying to
something maybe compared with previous
maybe a little bit better hopefully we
have to be more human Tyrion a neat
clean water you know shelter everything
you know and also the issue of the maybe
other question they may take it right so
ethnic
listen is bit problematic in Burma that
is legitimized by the colonial legacy I
think this is a study by the colonial
legacy because the different ethnic
different proud to be ethnic of course
they have to be proud their own ethnic
but the same they have no sense too much
because that we are keeping the colonial
legacy for this kind of ethnic politics
and ethnic you know or nationalism their
stake keeping and that very difficult to
be a state difficult position for to be
a reconciliation process but nobody
started to talk about for civic
nationalism that's a missing one no
politician talked about that this civic
nationalism
the same like you know even 1982
citizenship law is one of the problem
maker
people want to be ethnic Rohingya wanted
to be too much ethnic recognized ethnic
because if you are not recognized ethnic
of ethnic you cannot be a bond citizen
you can be citizen with the by law so
you have like another class of citizen
so that's part of the problem is this
decision law if you are not recognized
ethnic you cannot be a bounty disease
that is another barrier that most of the
group they want to be a legitimate
attorney because they are following the
mainstream polity nobody are penetrating
you know apart from this mainstream
politic like that so that's another
challenge that we have to be take time
to do awareness about civil is in this
more secure the country you know that
kind of things you know that government
have to be started and human regular
started you know thank you thank you
on your second question were you asking
why I see I think I think there's a
strong racial element to this as well
that's fed by fears of Miyama been
overwhelmed by cultures from the
subcontinent and because of perhaps more
distinct facial features there are you
know more aligned with sub-continental
groups then they almost provide evidence
that the western border is weak and the
western borders long have this moniker
of being the western gate and if the
western gate Falls then Yama will be
overwhelmed by cultures from the
subcontinent so I don't think you can
discount the racial element to this
violence it's often talked about in sort
of religious terms or ethnic terms but I
think there's a strong aspect when it
comes to you know we can apparently
identify ranger by their features we can
pick them out for attack the second
question wide range of stay in some
areas in northern reclined state and
leave others I don't really know I do I
mean the cynic in me would argue the the
military deliberately left some traces
of rare injured communities there for
the very reasons that we see now so that
they or the government could use that as
a kind of PR front to explain that you
know our strategy isn't complete
cleansing the people who left did so of
their own accord etc etc I haven't been
to northern what kind state since this
violence happened so I don't know what
was particular about those villages I do
know from the testimony that I got in
Bangladesh that the military had what
seemed like very clear very clear
strategy to massacre certain villages
Torche certain villages and then use
those as warnings to other villages
nearby that should you not follow you
know should you not heed our warning and
get out then this what happened to you
and that happened across northern
Rakhine State but for those that do
remain yeah I do wonder whether they are
just proof for the military that they're
not complete yeah I just wanted to add
that although I don't support forcible
international intervention if I were a
revenge' I would ask myself and I would
ask an international community why it is
that the international community did
intervene to save the Kosovo Muslims all
right a comparatively small crisis of
Muslims threatened in Europe and it
makes no move to send let's say UN
peacekeeping or monitoring forces in a
case that is much more violent much more
extensive and involves more than half a
million people so if I were a hundred
throats
I did so white and sand village and
laughs in Judea and mountain I think
some allons-y there because the bullets
are not closed
to the mountain mayor mountains the
bridge is closed to mayor mountain or
get up because they use a pool like
poker and strategy so I love the British
laughs far from the mountain so malloc
leaked and they're in such and canvas
care in the mountain video I think that
is one of the strategy the malechie are
using and that's why also that people
are I believe like if that situation is
not improved the people who are living
in put it out mostly also they are going
to live in very soon and wither with the
economic estar also I walk briefly with
the London law school for since study
sir so if we look at two thousand four
two thousand twelve like violence and
also the recent violence I interview or
sit where or mountains is all related
with their life be government's approach
act and I think that behind the Chinese
weekly involved and that's where in the
security composition is against their
resolution and also lying I have I have
to achieve Rach I'm Nationalist Party
also receive instant Fanning from China
so the shine is always keeping all like
westerns company out of fun rock I stay
so they can run the business and then
very sad further ohinki they are facing
like acne cleansing agenda sex so the
yeah so very involving the are the
businesses that issues in Rakhine State
currently
tells you like that the men are get out
night the Rohingya Kira they are bearing
a seaport and special economic so the
same the the bullish abanda and so if
you look at that sit tight
also the India are paid in the CEPA and
that is community who live there 2012
and if you look at the current come fly
in the mound or
kyenge house like
she said and that is that the roving
just complan see there so they're
kicking I think so
so lobster enter in the relationship one
last one let's comment and I will do
this film very quick the two points
right so and the whether or not the
Konami CLE dispossessed people join the
conflicts actually you could look at it
the other way because a lot of real
kinds that I talked to you in an inch
outdoor area which is not very far from
well actually they said that because of
the conflicts they become dispossessed
because there's no trade between them
and they are Bangladesh anymore and they
used to be really good when especially
with rice you know they could explore
rise to Bangladesh and also go to go
back to American of Burmese student
point the taiga is is actually it's
funny because if you are a permanent you
don't use diantha diantha is reserved
for katinka yaki linked it if someone
say I'm dying that it means that I'm nor
Burma right so it is ironic the Berman's
claiming that we are tying up because we
never say it in our everyday language
now if you would say Thai in that it
means that you're known gamma right so
that that yeah again to go back to the
civic nationalism or the Civic awareness
I think we have to start from very young
at at school when you go there and after
you sing your national anthem what you
do is you have to pray you have to say
say some bullets our prayers and then if
you are Muslim or Hindu a Christian you
stand out so the making of the other
constructing of other starts very young
we have to change that otherwise yeah
when you are like 10 or 10 11 your deity
in your head and you know who is the
other is yes it actually detects your
everything that the action and thinking
and yeah so it is very strong okay
please join me in thanking our panel
[Applause]
[Music]